so as we come out of this our
expectation is that there's going to be
good real estate out there unfortunately
because some restaurants aren't going to
survive this
um and the restaurants that were able to
uh weather the storm
are going to be a good position to grow
[Music]
chuck emerson thank you for joining me
asian box i love it
thank you well we love our raving fans
that's for sure
hey chuck uh thank you first of all for
all the amazing work that you're doing
with asian box i've had
a lot of people on this show so far uh
you're probably my favorite one i have
to say because you
brought you brought so much happiness to
me in my time in palo alto and that when
i will return to palo alto i'll
i'll continue having that great time but
you you bring such happiness to so many
different people across the chains of
asian box
that it's a really an honor to meet you
because i think asian box
is a different type of restaurant than a
lot of others and i'll let you
expand on that but chuck before we get
into that
talk to me a little bit about yourself
and how do you get to become the chief
executive officer
of a restaurant chain
well you know i've been in the business
since i got out of school and i spent a
lot of time with marie callender's
restaurant which is
you know a well-known chain um and then
i moved over to startups i actually did
life kitchen which was also in palo alto
um and i ended up meeting the founders
of asian box
and we had a good connection and in 2014
i came over and joined the team
to head up operations and you know with
their
so uh and then you know over time the
founder moved on and
i had an opportunity to move up and uh
you know i got to take over just before
uh covid entered our lives so it's been
a
been an exciting uh and challenging time
for sure
right i actually bumped into you i
remember in
one of the palo alto uh restaurants and
i remember sitting there and
and somehow i i came to realize that you
know the ceo of asian box is going to
come and i just thought of myself oh my
god you know i i've met a bunch of ceos
from the tech scene
but they're not nearly as exciting as
the ceo of asian box where i eat almost
every single day
so it was a very funny coincidence chuck
give me a little bit of insight into
what asian box is and
and why is it a bit of a different
restaurant than the average restaurant
we would see on the street well you know
we're vietnamese street food
um you know a couple of things i think
make make us different
is uh well we're 100 gluten-free um you
know
just naturally but with the ingredients
we use so you know anybody who's looking
for that
can feel comfortable and safe um you
know vietnamese food isn't you know your
everyday food
and you know with our ingredients we
have
top quality ingredients which i think
separates us from some of the
competition
and you know the the food travels well
um you know we have good portions
um we were founded on build your own
which you know people really enjoy being
having that flexibility of being able to
you know create their flavor profile
that they want the box that they want
and
in addition now we've we've added about
a dozen
uh signature boxes as well so to make it
easier for people that just want to come
out and pick something to ship together
right so
so when you walk in you get you get the
workout you got you get those types of
things
and but you can also create your own box
and i have to say that one of the things
that really
um impressed me when i got introduced to
asian box i believe it was
2013 early 2014 and i
i was just running a high school startup
and i remember we would always walk to
uh to town country to eat at asian box
and
i remember that you know the everything
just seemed so natural
all the way from the plate to the
utensils the actual food seemed so fresh
how do you get that how do you bring
that feeling to the customer
well you know you give a lot of credit
to you know the founders that put it
together you know grace nguyen who's the
chef
um you know it's her family recipes um
you know chad and frank who are the
other two founders you know really put
together
you know everything from the compostable
container to the sourcing you know
working locally where possible
and you know again the freshest uh
quality ingredients
um and you know the good news is you
know um
that particular location that's our
flagship store that i know you've been a
regular of for quite some time and
and you know we feed you know stanford
we feed the hospital
we feed the high school and uh we've
been very fortunate you know we've
we have a big following there uh in
addition to catering
which again you know with our food the
way it holds uh the way it travels we
you know we've built a
well prior to cope it built a strong uh
catering business as well so
i think all of that kind of comes
together you know the biggest thing is
is the team you know the the manager uh
that we've had the managers we've had
the one
now who's been in charge of that store
wendy for several years
you know it's all about you know she's
the leader she sets the pace training
the staff
developing the staff and you know all of
them are you know
live around the community um they all
are passionate about
you know the food what we're trying to
do as far as uh you know the lifestyle
and um and just taking care of customers
you know and and you know so with the
smile
right you're giving a lot of autonomy
and credibility to the restaurant
manager wendy from
town and country so first of all thank
you wendy but
uh chuck you're the ceo of the chain
what is your responsibility then
as the ceo once you have you know a
really amazing people running the local
businesses
well you know i think it you know again
it starts with the people i mean
you know i've been fortunate you know we
have uh
eight stores now um and
we have eight great managers that you
know care
um that you know if i was going to start
another company i would happily bring
any of them over
and you know to me that's kind of the
the barometer that i want to use that
you know these people all
you know to your point you know they
have autonomy they feel a sense of
ownership
uh they go that extra mile all of our
cashiers are empowered to take care of
any issue
you know it's not you know they all have
a level of ownership or if there's a
problem
we're going to take care of it and it's
not going to be through a process it's
just going to be right now
and you know getting those teams
building them
and then you know helping them build
their benches and
you know keeping them focused on what's
important you know right now obviously
we can't stress safety enough
um with everything going on in the world
so we spend a lot of time talking about
you know that what does that mean and
what's the perception of the consumer
and and you know being very um you know
ahead of
what the guest expects that that makes a
lot of sense and and how do you
think more critically about what the
guest expects because
as the ceo i'm imagining that you're
setting the tone for the expectation
across all the chains right aligning the
vision aligning the strategy that
at the end the the great people that are
working there they should
they should aspire to so how how do you
adjust to that role
and what is some of the thinking process
that goes on behind that
well you know it's kind of two-part when
you know you you know it's the business
of where are we going
you know long-term um you know whether
that's the marketing whether that's
you know new menu items whether that's
um you know different promotions or you
know it
you know whatever we're offering um but
i think
you know what's more important is
keeping it's
very simple you know for the managers
you know it's
you know the restaurant business is
really
a lot of common sense and hospitality
and if everybody understands that we're
here to make the guest happy
then you know that that's our barometer
to
making our decisions then it simplifies
it you know
and you know the guests want the food to
come out you know fast at a high quality
um you know obviously fresh and you know
made properly so you know our procedures
need to be in place
and and validated you know we use we
have a third party service that comes in
and acts as the health department
in addition to the health department and
grades all the restaurants
and you know we have a culinary person
who goes around and
works with the culinary teams and and
you know um
teaching them new techniques or just you
know keeping them on track um
you know we do obviously all the safety
procedures you would expect any
restaurant to do temperature checks and
you know all those throughout the day um
you know but the biggest thing is
is the employees caring you know and if
they care
um you know they're gonna take care of
it and
you know if they look at it as okay i
want the experience
i'm gonna deliver the experience i want
to have and we talk about that
you know pre-shift meetings as far as
you know it
you know we want to go fast but we don't
want to rush you know so the boxes need
to come out perfect every time and
being that it's customizable there's a
lot of you know
a lot of different variations of
modifiers
um in addition the fact there's a lot of
sensitivity some people
are you know certainly obviously
gluten-free we don't worry about because
we're 100 gluten-free but
you know we have peanuts and other
allergens that are there
and educating our team to be able to
you know give the guests what they want
uh consistently
is a big deal and you know consistency
you know is the biggest um factor i
think you know when i teach managers and
teach the employees and
you know from my leadership consistency
is that number one word because
people can trust that you know if if
you're consistent
you know we have a lot of regulators
like yourself um you know i know we have
a gentleman out at
um at palo alto that comes in i think
five days a week and get to work out
and obviously he wants that workout and
he wants it that way
right and you know we have a lot of
examples of that and
you know we're very transparent um you
know i get a lot of feedback from the
guests and you know i answer as many as
i can
um and um they care too
you know they they understand that you
know being gluten free
and um you know being a fast casual
especially right now they're very
supportive
that that makes a lot of sense so give
me a little bit of um
context as to how many restaurants are
there
what is sort of the circulation
obviously just the the parameters that
you can share
yeah you know we we opened the first
store into early 2012
and then we opened uh two more you know
the following couple of years
uh 2000 um you know late 2012 actually
2013. i came on in 2014.
um you know we we went through a period
where we didn't grow and then we opened
you know seven stores uh pretty quickly
you know from 2016 uh through 2018
and you know we we peaked at four in
southern california and six in northern
california at 10.
unfortunately when the pandemic hit um
we you know made the tough decision to
let two stores go in southern california
and then we have another store in
downtown l.a that's temporarily closed
in part because of the pandemic but in
part the
landlords remodeling the center so it
was just you know coincidental timing so
so we have seven stores operating today
one in irvine and six in northern
california and
we're throughout the peninsula from down
from san jose up to the marina
chestnut store um you know burlingame
mountain view
um and you know so that's kind of where
we're at today you know we
we are raising money right now we have a
series f open
uh we're looking we feel like this is
the opportunity to grow right now
even though these are very challenging
times um
you know we've weathered the storm to
date
and we feel like we're going to come out
stronger we've been forced like a lot of
our peers
to make tough cuts uh to really look at
our business and
you know so to be trimmed the fat so to
speak you know being very efficient with
our labor cost with our
car in our food cost um and looking at
every expense
you know from our pos system to you know
everything you could imagine insurances
and we feel like we've been very
efficient at a necessity we've
you know we thought we were efficient
you know we spent a lot of 2019
um really kind of um becoming a more
efficient company more profitable
company getting what you know what we
call our prime cost down which is the
term and you know combination of food
and labor a term in the restaurant
industry
and you know we really got that down to
where um
we could grow and potentially start
franchising but then cope it hit so
um we we looked even deeper and you know
made some
some tough decisions so as we come out
of this our expectation is that there's
going to be
good real estate out there unfortunately
because some restaurants aren't going to
survive this
um and the restaurants that were able to
weather the storm
are going to meet a good position to
grow so our hope
um that's a very interesting way of
looking at it
yeah yeah you know and you know our our
thought progress
is that as we get into next year um
you know right now where we're at is we
basically lost our catering business
and you know i know we're not alone in
that you know and and that's you know 20
of our business and you know that
hopefully will come back when people
feel comfortable going back into the
offices
and and getting you know getting a
comfort level and that might not be till
you know 2022 realistically and we
understand that
uh but our our other business you know
our partners with people like doordash
and you know grubhub
and and ubereats you know has helped us
survive in addition to
um you know we partnered with ola or
with spot on which is a
up-and-coming pos system and they have
the ability for online ordering
and app and all those things so we
flexed right
into that and we was kind of already in
process but we really flexed hard into
that to
maximize the guests being able to order
easily and comfortably safely whether
they want the food delivered or pick up
with non-contact um you know we have all
that
happening and so you know we built the
trust back and
over time we built our business back up
to where really the only thing where
were uh missing from last year is
catering and
like i said i expect that to come back
eventually um
so so in a way even though we've gone
through a
very challenging situation we're in a
good position to grow
and our hope is to um you know raise
some capital
and sign a couple leases next year
i have to say that i'm really inspired
by your take on
the positioning that you're saying we've
entered this pandemic we had to make
some very tough decisions we closed
two restaurants we've pretty much lost
the catering business because
there really is no catering in 2020 and
likely 2021
yet we realize that there are
opportunities for those that are able to
climb over the hill even if they're
wounded but there are going to be
opportunities to grow
into into an a relatively emptier market
whether it's in real estate or whether
it's in customer acquisition
and i'm sure that uh that you're
thinking about that but i have to say
that you know as a young entrepreneur
and not coming from the restaurant scene
i really love that entrepreneurial way
of thinking of
of of you know going strong and saying
okay what what what is going to happen
in here and how can we come out stronger
chuck paint me a picture when when
covert hits what are the first steps
that the ceo makes uh in the restaurant
business or what did you
have to do immediately as kobet hits in
order to you know
adapt and and sort of align everybody to
this new reality that nobody knows
what's gonna happen
yeah you know i think i like a lot of
people um
you know i can look at our our
financials
and march 17th you know the the day
after
um you know was truly really announced
on a you know national level that
hey we need to lock down and start
buying toilet paper
um we we really at that point
had to look at you know everything and
you know we made some tough decisions i
closed four stores immediately that i
knew were going to be either
um high traffic like the mall location
the downtown location that i knew you
know the offices weren't going to be
there
and you know so we paused and we kind of
evaluated
what what the true impact was going to
be and you know we took a hit
pretty immediate like a lot of people um
and then we started getting strategic
and thinking about okay you know
what do we need to do you know we went
to our partners as i mentioned earlier
uh the third-party delivery services
that we use we went to
our pos system and said okay you know
how do we make this easier for the
guests
um and we pivoted to that pretty quickly
and you know we've seen you know some of
our competitors you take like habit you
know they did makeshift drive-throughs
in their parking lots because they knew
they had to compete
um you know with you know the the burger
places that had
you know drive-through so so we knew
that we needed to
make it as easy as possible for the
guests you know where possible to offer
curbside
you know and we had some inherent
challenges but we worked through those
and um you know and i think just
you know telling the teams you know the
general manager is like hey
communicate with your teams let them
know what's going on
um you know let's help them take care of
themselves you know we had to obviously
cut back a lot of hours
you know help them you know figure out
how to get themselves taken care of
whether it was how to get unemployment
or whatever the case may be
because you know we're all in this
together and you know we had to furlough
some people immediately and
you know in heavy communication with
them and you know because at the end of
the day
you know the hope was everybody was
going to come back and
we wanted to make sure that they were
all still there and loyal
um and you know so and we're still
fighting that you know i have three
people on furlough right now
still that you know the catering
department and the downtown l.a store
that i mentioned earlier that's
temporarily closed
and but i've talked to i talked to those
three people you know every other week
and
they're ready to come back and they're
anxious and you know they've all taken
part-time jobs because they've had to
but they know that i'm committed to them
and you know as soon as we can get them
back we will
i think that one of the hardest things
to deal with as a leader in in any
situation but especially in this
situation is this uncertainty and
communicating that
through that uncertainty and one of the
things that i've been hearing a lot
is this effort to over communicate and
under communicate
especially in a time like cover 19 and i
think that when you're mentioning that
you're maintaining this
the responsibility towards them and
maintaining that communication then
i think that that's a that's exactly the
inspiration that i'm looking
as i'm talking to a lot of others uh
chuck uh before we leave i wanna uh
thank you for being so generous with
your time uh both here and
and with asian box a very funny
coincidence that a guest
that is on the show as well elisa
pelling she's also a board member of
asian box which
just blew my mind yeah but it makes
perfect sense uh
she's a very close friend and very very
impressive
and and i really want to thank you for
for sharing those insights and that
personal experience
at the ceo of a of a great chain that is
just growing i can't wait to see where
asian box will continue to grow
but before we leave i have to ask for
the most important and difficult
question which is three words that you
would use to describe yourself
um good question um i think
consistent you know um you know when
you know whenever you make decisions you
got to be consistent just like we want
the food to come out consistently that
way people know where they stand and
uh know what's coming um i think um
you know right now evolving
and i don't know if that's the best word
but you know we're evolving
uh each day as to what happens you know
in this in this industry and in the
world and
we got to be able to to change with that
and be open-minded that
what you did yesterday may not be a
successful tomorrow
if you're not open to change um and then
you know
um i don't know you know i think
you know communication once again is a
key word i don't know if that describes
me
that's more like doing something but um
you know i'm very big
i think that's the perfect description
yeah and um i love my
all the managers you know and a lot of
our employee all the employees
have my number a lot of them will text
just different ideas and that's how we
get better
and you know that's important i
appreciate you taking the time
and uh being a big fan of our company
wonderful chuck thank you very very much
this is great
and stay safe and stay healthy and i'm
looking forward to seeing you again
around the restaurants likewise thanks
you